the valerian world is chaos right now
we've got a brand new
mohawk smoking stunning gigantic walling
agent from the cosmos
ready to shake up the game the valrant
champions tour
is on its way to its next stage and 100
thieves just yanked yet
another nacs go mainstay oh yeah
and we've got a land coming up a real
land in 2021
all right we're well on our way to two
million subs here on this youtube
channel
if you like our videos if you like the
score's content
make sure to scroll down hit that
subscribe button and make sure
notifications are on
so you never miss a video okay guys
you've
got to have your head on a swivel if
you're a valor at fan right now
there is a lot to cover in this video
whether you're a silver casual like me
or a hardcore egamer and huge esports
fan
so let's get into it first things first
we've got a brand new agent
astra and she's not another brain dead
duelist
like reyna you can tell a person's
character
by their first action
she's a badass star-wielding controller
who comes complete with smokes
a breach-like stun and what hiko likes
to call
a suck i'm sucking sure i sucked shirt
he's in my suckage suck
without a number and her ultimate
well it's a huge [ __ ] wall
oh okay oh oh my god
this looks sick that's unreal
the way these abilities work is you go
into your astral form where everything
turns purple
and you can place down stars and then
you can activate those stars
at any time in the round and make them
become a smoke
a stun or a suck i would say that astra
falls into a category with brimstone and
omen who are the primary smokers in the
game which of course
end up becoming some of the most
important characters in both your ranked
games
and in the pro scene because much like
counter-strike you need smokes to take
or retake a site effectively so needless
to say i think we're both going to see a
ton
of astra in pro play and you're really
going to want to see your rank teammates
lock her in instead of that ever present
third duelist for me this is
exactly what i want to see out of
new valor and agents she's unique her
playstyle is
uber customizable and she plays really
well with your team
plus you can combo her ability super
well with other agents
i am counting down the days before i get
my first suck
into a killjoy alt or a raised grenade
here's hiko
on astra well eating what sounds like
some nuts
if you have an astra only have to worry
about b and she uses all five of her
stars for b
on like split we'll say i feel like
you'll never be able to go b
you thought the suck was enough but wait
till you get sucked and concussed at the
same time
so i think she'll be good it's gonna be
situational
you can probably play her as smokes if
you really wanted to
i think you lose a lot of her like what
she's good at
all of the positives asides there are
some key
downsides to astra much like breach your
team
really has to work together to make
astra work
i mean when you're in your astral form
you're literally standing
on the map not moving meditating so when
you queue into rank and your whole team
is either baiting or not using their mic
astra can feel pretty bad
with that in mind 10 still think she's
going to be broken
this character is ridiculous this is the
this character is the perfect defending
character i don't care what anybody else
says
i take back what i said about 90 pick
rate and pro play this will be 100 pick
for it
conveniently the release of astra segues
nicely into the next piece of news to
come out of valorem this week
ethan leaving evil geniuses cs go team
to join a hundred thief's
valorem team to play some more team
focused agents
in place of dicey who's a jet one trick
the move came with one of the funniest
self owns in esports twitter history
now if you've been following
pro-valorent like i have this move may
have come
as a complete shock to you after all a
hundred thieves did win the biggest
tournament we've seen
so far in the game first strike and the
youthful combination
of asana and dicey did a lot to mix well
with the
boomer cs go players in steel and hika
as for nitro
well he's just [ __ ] cracked man
actually
right there dude thanks heaven one
second
actually went pretty deep on the move on
stream after the announcement
let's talk about the elephant in the
room how about that first as far as
resumes
i don't think there's some anybody that
is better than ethan
from cs that has switched over yet ethan
is also 20 years old
people are people are coming into this
saying like oh my god i can't believe
they picked up another old
veteran cs player bro ethan's literally
20. he's probably
on the number two n a team for a long
time
and for for some periods of time they
were battling liquid to be the number
one team for a while
we are looking into and experimenting
with only a single duelist
lineup so like you heard from the man
himself this move is a combination of
things
first they see ethan as a massive get
someone who could be
one of the best players in n a second
they want to play some non-jet comps and
less duelists in general
and third this is going to allow nitro
their best player to flex more on other
agents
clearly heco and 100 thieves see the
transition from csgo
to bauern as trivial given that they
have a tournament in two days to decide
whether they get into masters or not
after winning first strike let's just
say there's some pressure on these boys
to qualify
now i also see this move and hiko's
comments about trying out different
compositions as an
interesting nugget of information to
come out of all this
so far in north america pro games have
been pretty puggy
all things considered we've watched a
lot of rainers and jets take gunfights
against each other for 15 rounds but as
far as 100
thieves is concerned with this move the
addition of astra and other agents like
her in the future
we could see valorent transitioning to a
more execute heavy
big brain style like we're used to
seeing with all the gods of eu
counter-strike now with that said it's
not like ethan can't click on heads
yep three killed
they can't go over the wall
oh oh okay
[Music]
now the last thing i want to touch on
when it comes to this ethan move is what
it means for north american
counter-strike because unfortunately
ethan has now joined the likes of vanity
leaf
automatic and his teammate nitro as nacs
go players who lost the roster spot
and then had to leave cs go and based on
the fact that 100 thieves announced him
30 minutes after eg announced that he
was leaving the roster
he wasn't exactly shopping around
looking for other teams
which really reinforces the sad state of
affairs that is nacs go during the covet
era
you better have a spot on team liquid or
evil geniuses
or you literally have to switch esports
i also think that this is kind of a
feels bad for valorant too
we want to see that new young cracked
any talent
shine in this game not it be a place
that
cs go players go when they can't find a
contract now to move on to a less
depressing subject
along with the new battle pass the new
agent
the cheap rip-off of the karambit riot
games announced
that the second stage of masters in the
valoran champions tour
will take place on land in reykjavik
iceland
yeah yeah you heard that right a real
[ __ ] land in 2021
[Music]
the event will take place may 24th to
30th
right after riot hosts the league of
legends mid-season invitational in the
same place
and this is massive news if you're a
valor in esports head
after a full year we are finally
going to see teams from all over the
world
compete against each other in a real
land environment
it's time to figure out who the s-tier
region
really is in this game now if you're
unaware
or just incredibly confused because it
is incredibly [ __ ] confusing
here's where we're at in the valor
champions tour this weekend
is the final closed qualifier for the
challenger series
these eight teams will be competing
beginning this coming thursday to
finalize
north american masters one which will
see the winners from the three
n a challenger series events compete to
get to the champion stage
which at least at this point seems like
worlds and i think it's safe to say that
you can
sort of think of masters as majors
this same circuit will happen three
times this year
we've got three challenger series three
masters
all culminating in one valor in
champions what this latest announcement
is telling us though is that masters
2 is not going to be regional we'll have
online qualifiers
all culminating in an international land
in
iceland which is music to my esports
deprived ears
and there you have it quite possibly the
busiest few weeks
in the young history of pro valerie
since you saw me on this show last
if i get running sprayed by the frenzy
or the stinger
one more time i'm gonna break my
keyboard riot has stepped in they've
nerfed the frenzy
they nerfed the stinger into oblivion
and they've tweaked the rifles
enough to get the gameplay to a place
that we're
mostly happy with and now we've got one
of the most
pressure packed weekends in the esports
young
life coming up especially if you're 100
thieves or tsm
i for one am stoked to play some astra
and stoke to see
what the lineup of teams will end up
being for masters 1 in north america
i just have one last small
ass riot games please nerf the [ __ ]
bucky next
this is free youtube content
[Music]
my take on valorem characters is that
the best ones are not like cs go but
their utility isn't
overpowered if that makes sense like for
example
you know jet mains are jet mains
whatever but i think jets like a good
character because
jet's not like she's not straight out of
cs go right like the thing that makes
um valor agents cool is when they're
wholly balanced focused designs
i'm an actor i'm an artist baby
i'm an anime i bring the personality to
the table
to the table okay